AND UNREGULATED.
>> Bret: BRIT, THANK YOU.
>> THANKS, BRET.
>> Bret: INVESTIGATING AN
ACCUSATION FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIAL THAT THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OVERRULED DOZENS OF SECURITY
CLEARANCE DNELS.
SO NAMES ON THAT LIST ARE
VERY WELL KNOWN.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE
HERRIDGE HAS SPECIFICS
TONIGHT.
>> ACCORDING TO THE LETTER,
THE DEMOCRATIC CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOUSE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE IS THREATENING TO
ISSUE SUBPOENAS IF THE WHITE
HOUSE FAILS TO MAKE RECORDS
AND WITNESSES AVAILABLE
AFTER A WHISTLEBLOWER TRISHA
NUBOLD CLAIMED TWO DOZEN
SECURITY CLEARANCE DENIALS.
CONGRESSMAN CONSUMPTION
RELEASED A MEMO DOCUMENTING
THE COMPLAINTS ACCORDING TO
THE WHISTLEBLOWER THE
INDIVIDUALS HAD A WIDE RANGE
OF SERIOUS DISQUALIFYING
ISSUES FROM FOREIGN
INFLUENCE, CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST, TO FINANCIAL
PROBLEMS AND EVEN CRIMINAL
CONDUCT.
THE PRESIDENT'S SON AND
ADVISOR RESPONDED ON THE
INGRAHAM.
>> WE HAVE BEEN TOTALLY
VETTED AND VINDICATED ON ALL
OF THOSE THINGS.
IT'S A COMPLICATED TIME IN
SERVICE.
EVERYONE MAKES ALL KINDS OF
ACCUSATIONS.
>> DEMOCRATS WANT RECORD FOR
CURRENT FORMER OFFICIALS
INCLUDING JOHN BOLTON,
MICHAEL FLYNN, JARED
KUSHNER, IVANKA TRUMP, JOHN
McEN TEE, ROB PORTER AMONG
OTHERS.
THE WHISTLEBLOWER SAYS THE
WHITE HOUSE STOPPED CREDIT
HISTORY CHECKS AND LOUED A
HIGH NUMBER OF INCIDENT
CRIPPLE CLEARANCES SAYING
QUOTE I WOULD NOT BE DOING A
SERVICE TO MYSELF MIKESELL
COUNTRY AND MY CHILDREN IF I
SAT BACK KNOWING THAT THE
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE COULD
IMPACT NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHEN THE CLEARANCE STORY
BROKE LAST MONTH, A SENIOR
HOUSE DEMOCRAT ALLEGED A
PATTERN.
>> I THINK IT WAS AN ABUSE
OF POWER; THE PRESIDENT HAS
A RIGHT TO DO A LOT OF
THINGS HE CAN ABUSE HIS
POWER IN DOING THAT.
>> SAYING THE DEMOCRATS
PLAYED GAME INTERVIEWING A
WITNESS EARLY SATURDAY
MORNING.
PROVIDING REPUBLICANS WITH
NO OPPORTUNITY TO PREPARE.
THE COMMITTEE'S RANKING
REPUBLICAN SAID THE
WHISTLEBLOWER HAD A HARD
TIME NAMING NAMES.
AND ONE ALLEGED CLEARANCE
VIOLATION INCLUDED A JANITOR
AT A GOVERNMENT'S OFFICE
SPACE AND SUPPLIES AGENCY.
>> THOSE ARE NOT REAL
INVESTIGATIONS THOSE ARE
FISHING EXPEDITIONS.
THE PRESIDENT HAS ABSOLUTE
AUTHORITY TO GRANT CLEARANCE
TO WHOM HE FEELS WILL GIVE
HIM BEST ADVICE IN THE
INTEREST OF THE UNITED
STATES.
>> QUESTION WHETHER SENIOR
AIDS TO SECRETARY OF STATE
CLINTON SHOULD HAVE BEEN
GRANTED CLEARANCES.
N. A ADDITION THE BACK LOCK
IS A LONG STANDING ISSUE OF